it's crazy i i got in a debate with aoc
like aoc uh union stuff yeah what was
the aoc unions uh she loves unions so
she never had a union job her life
and by the way was a bartender yeah yeah
anybody should know about the union like
i didn't nothing against unions like you
that's what the perfect example i i just
don't like what do you i don't i don't
understand how she understands something
listen
the idea of a union i think is noble
it's like you need union this country
needed unions you had manufacturing jobs
people working [ __ ] million hours a
day you needed it but
i had a dead spin which is the worst
company that ever [ __ ] lived
they're the worst they're they all they
do is [ __ ] [ __ ] and moan and try to
[ __ ] get clow chase us they're the
[ __ ] worst and they change gawker all
these well i've i've been around for 20
years barcelona they've been around for
20 years so i [ __ ] hated them for
basically close to 20 years and they
created
and they created they created a union
and it's like guess what they [ __ ]
still went out of business all their
writers got [ __ ] fired because
they're talentless [ __ ] losers in my
business you don't need a union if
you're talented you get a job yeah like
you don't need it there there's but fine
every industry is different they all got
fired and the union's like we're getting
[ __ ] not treated right and i made a
joke about them i'm like where's your
union now tough guys they're not they're
you're still all getting fired it was
just
anything i can do to needle dead spin
i'm gonna do it yeah aoc comes out of
the [ __ ] clouds i never talked to her
i barely knew who she was yeah and
tweeted at me like you can't be
anti-union whatever i'm like oh all
right here we go aoc so i started going
back with her people were filing
complaints from the national labor
relations board i had to agree to issue
like an apology being like i if people
want to create a union at barstool they
could it's so [ __ ] up
our guys tried to create a fake union
and trick like the people who hated me
be like dave's trying to shut down our
union like
and then there's articles actually
treating that as a real real
that's how [ __ ] up i thought our world
is i saw the headline and i thought that
was real no [ __ ] no it was like
like my friends like just [ __ ] with
the media but isn't that crazy yes yes
is that crazy that i yeah that's how
[ __ ] up it is oh yeah and you got
tricked and you're gen z you know what i
mean you're like a giant internet dude i
got all the apps yeah i think i said i
treat our our you're right you guys have
locker room it's like oh these guys want
a [ __ ] credit union i'll quit and see
how their union does like what you were
talking like but we bust balls that's
what we do but people take what we say
internally and that's something that as
we've grown
you know we start
it was me then there's two guys and
there's three guys and we're just
sitting around a room with a camera
internet 1.0 no one's paying attention
and we continued to talk like that as we
continued to grow and the world
continued to change
things got taken differently sometimes
out of context some again it's like i
think we're joking i don't mean to
offend people that kaepernick that whole
story i just told would we do it now not
in a [ __ ] million zillion years but
your intentions aren't bad i think
correct and by the way nobody said a
word about it like until it was time
until blm happened they wait and it
wasn't just us it was a lot of people
they went back it's like what have i've
always said all right we've been doing
this for 20 years if you think we are as
mean-spirited and hated and bigoted and
racist as you think we are yeah i think
you'd have a couple more examples
than what you were able to do in 20
years of we don't
dead been an example gawker they deleted
their entire twitter
like they went back deleted all i
haven't deleted dick like everything
i've said for 20 years is there go wow
yeah go find it you're brave man wow
well i i know what i say and what i
don't say i know when people are lying
about me because it's like i don't talk
like that i know when they're not lying
about me
but it's you know it is what it is it is
what it is
you